but I'm joined Now by The Shadow
International Trade secretary Nick
Thomas Simmons a very good morning to
you and a very happy birthday I
understand
very good morning great to join you and
I appreciate the birthday wishes thank
you what a way to start your birthday
here on Sky News it's good to have it's
good to have you with us just in light
of those comments from Jeremy Hunt uh
I'd love your reaction uh if I may would
Labor uh be content with with seeing a
recession if it did mean uh that
inflation came down
no government should be ever be content
to see recession and what what we are
seeing I'm afraid are the consequences
here of all these failed and Wasted
Years of conservative rule we're only
even now a few months away from that
absolutely disastrous uh trust quote
mini budget people are paying the Tory
mortgage premium up and down the country
and people are still dealing with the
consequences of this Tory chaos the
result up and down the country our
families really feeling the pinch in
this cost of living crisis and frankly
this government has no credible plan to
restore growth and put the country on
that sustainable stable long-term path
that the country needs to be on to
generate that economic growth and to
ease the cost of living process for
family bodies up and down the country
certainly inflation is proving a very
big challenge not just here but also in
Industries
as well and certainly the chancellor has
said he will do whatever it takes in
order to bring down inflation would
labor be prepared to do whatever it
takes as well
well we would be prepared to put into
place our strategy for growth and to
make choices and to set priorities and
what we've seen from this government
this latest uh conservative government
when they've had to make choices they
don't stand on the side of ordinary
families you think recently of the the
pensions changes that this government
made when there was a specific problem
with doctors and retaining doctors which
of course we need to do instead of
Simply coming up with a solution for
doctors pensions and as has previously
happened for example with judges
pensions they decided to give this
enormous uh giveaway of a billion pounds
to the wealthiest the very wealthiest
people up and down the country always
politics is about choices and priorities
and this government does not stand on
the side of working people and I'm
afraid listen to the chancellor uh just
a brief clip of the chancellor there I
have little confidence in that uh
changing in the near future okay so it's
very easy to bash the government isn't
it it's much easier to criticize when
you're outside the tent in opposition
what would labor have done differently
in the current climate
well first and foremost we you have to
provide economic uh stability and first
and foremost you need political uh
stability the government has been
running through crisis to crisis uh you
know the the three prime ministers all
the chancellors uh we're supposed to
have a skill strategy instead I think
we've had uh five recent education
secretary so the first thing you need to
do is to provide uh that stability then
you need a plan for growth Labor's
guiding mission in government will be to
get the fastest growing economy in the
G7 now how will we achieve that well
we've set out uh our green Prosperity
plan our climate investment pledge a
clean energy Sprint by 2030 as we move
to uh Renewables uh as we create the
green jobs of the future and we insulate
19 million homes and what that will do
is give us both both energy security for
the future so we don't rely on dictators
like Putin but also lower bills because
energy bills are such an enormous part
of the moment of families budgets and
that's what we need to do yeah I mean
these are long-term plans though aren't
they and and actually the the major
urgent issues need to be dealt with
right now and is one of the issues not
that we've potentially cut ourselves off
from our biggest trading partner the EU
would labor change that
well we certainly uh will be looking at
how we can ease back ease trading
barriers between EU and the UK we we
won't be uh rejoining the Customs Union
or the single Market it's not a natural
interest to reopen the debates of the
past and we won't be doing that but
certainly in our trading relationship
with the EU we need to lower those
barriers so for example we could
negotiate a Veterinary agreement with
the EU and what that would mean is on
things like agricultural products
agri-food products we really could
reduce tariff barriers to contribute to
making the cost of food cheaper for
people across the country and that is so
important because we've just been having
that that discussion uh about halving
inflation but of course food inflation
is running at a significantly higher
level than the headline rate of
inflation that's Pub published and that
is affecting families every week up and
down the country
changing the trading barriers is
actually a practical thing we could do
to make a difference
do you think brexit has added to higher
inflation
it's the conservatives handling of the
economy and the conservatives handling
of the deal that they negotiated with
the European Union that's caused the
immediate problems we've had 13 years
now of conservative government 13 Wasted
Years in which growth throughout that
time has been anemic they just haven't
had a proper plan for growth they still
don't have a proper plan for groups and
that's why by the way when you speak to
people on the doorstep and you put that
question has any public service got
better under the conservatives the
answer to that is no that's not the
fault of the Fantastic people who work
in them it's the fault of the government